[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you take a second and hit the Subscribe
button appreciate that the thumbs up
also helps today is a kind of a cool one
it was the last second ask because of
what we just came from which was burning
man my friend Jason sherka was there as
well and he's like we should do an
episode about burning man and tell
people about what really happened and
what was really going on Jason is an
awesome guy he is a spiritual teacher
he's an author he's written four books
he's writings Fifth and he's a big
YouTuber so he has tons of videos on
YouTube he's really just trying to like
expose the truth so there's a lot of
disclosure information and people that
have come forward to share their
information if you're curious about
what's really going on in deep State and
in the world and with spirituality and
Consciousness today's episode was all
about Burning Man and for those who
don't know there was a a bunch of rain
that came and it sort of Trapped
everyone and it was a muddy mess and
FEMA got involved and the president was
alerted about it and there was it was
just became a really big deal we wanted
to take this time to clarify the truth
and also just talk about the event
itself because I think there's a lot of
perception about it and we want to clear
up what our reality was about burning
man why we go what's great what's
available so we got into all that and I
think this will be a very educational
video about Not only Burning Man itself
but how sort of you show up in it and
what it says about you whether you go or
whether you observe and whether you
judge it please enjoy the episode let me
know what you think in the comments let
me know if you've been there maybe maybe
I saw you all great athletes have one
thing in common they take care of their
bodies it's something that we do from a
young age whether we work out the food
that we eat how we prepare our mind this
is all part of becoming a great athlete
and one thing that I do every single
morning is I drink ag1 I do it before I
have coffee I do it before I eat any
food I really feel like for me it's
helped my gut health it's made my
stomach just feel like less bloated and
more calm throughout the day it handles
all food so much better I'm putting like
75 high quality ingredients into my body
first thing in the day which makes a
huge difference even if I'm traveling I
use the travel packs I was in Europe for
six weeks every single day I put ag1
into my body so if a comprehensive
solution is what you need from your
supplement routine then ag-1 is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to drinkag1.com pretty
intense that's drink ag1.com pretty
intense check it out I think talking
about like what it was really like and
our favorite parts are good because I
think people are really curious about
that I didn't know what to expect when I
went there for the first time like I
rode out onto the Playa at night in the
dark like I had only been at like the
trailer and so it was such a unique
experience so like what do you love what
do you love about burning man why
because you've been twice right yeah so
I'll give you I'll give you my my
background with it the the first time I
went was in 2019
and it was it was a normal year you know
nothing out of the ordinary I personally
can't stay there for like a week it's
it's too much for me so I went for a few
days I experienced it I explored it it
was awesome the first time I went I
didn't go to the camp I just drove in I
parked an RV and that's it and and
that's what I had a ticket though right
yeah yeah of course you just drove in
you had a parking pass there were people
like parachuting in it was crazy it was
really really crazy and after that I'm
like you know what this was enough this
was good for me I don't know if I'll
ever go back
then what happened was about six months
ago I was I had this idea and I'm like
you know what I'm working with this
technology it's like this this modality
called Energy enhancement system I
called the CEO of the company I'm like
what do you what do you think of
bringing this technology to this event
and he's like I think it's great but I
said listen we got to create it as a
form of an art piece it can't be you
know any form of like commodity of any
sort so that's a really unique art piece
and did you see it in the pyramid did
you see those really big towers all
around yeah they were they were in each
Corner 14 foot towers of this like
really cool looking technology that we
work with all around the world and
basically that was the reason why I went
this time it was to bring that as an
installation to Burning Man and
basically to bring light to a younger
generation of individuals and to to make
more people aware of this so we went for
that reason and then everything just I
mean it got crazy and really interesting
and beautiful at the same time seeing
how people really came together in times
of need yeah yeah what's your favorite
part like what what would you say is
like something that would bring you back
probably the I would say the community
aspect of it the fact that people are
just together the fact that there's no
exchange of money there yeah I mean you
know that you know you there there is
nothing everybody's just like you want
this you want that so it's like a
beautiful thing and it's it you know
it's two things because when you have
that much Beauty you always have a
spectrum right you have this this both
sides of things so free will is a great
thing because you can choose to be the
most beautiful being you would like to
be in like a Godly light and you can
choose to be the exact opposite if you
choose to do that and it's really up to
what you want to do and who you want to
be when you're there and of course
everybody that I spend time with chose
the beautiful path and chose community
and that's really what I saw
collectively all around but what was
your experience like
everything's available choose your
adventure like everything is available
so you know are there orgies yep I don't
know I never saw them I never walked
into one like are there also
um beautiful talks being had about
Consciousness and quantum physics and
things like that yep there's totally
talks about that that are totally
different it's very much like
everything's available my favorite part
is the contrast
yeah it could be on the you could be on
the Esplanade for people that don't know
basically
Burning Man is shaped think of a clock
and from 2 till 10 that's all
campgrounds and so the first inside row
of that is called Esplanade and then
there's the then there's for each letter
goes a b c d e f g h i j maybe it goes
to J it goes to k k and so it goes to K
and those are all the roads out and then
from that empty space of the of the two
to ten range that is open and that's
just a fence that lines the perimeter on
the outside which is called Deep Playa
once you get past sort of once you get
past the temple because the temple kind
of finishes the circle of the camps past
that is called Deep Playa and so once
you like get out to deep Playa it's so
beautiful and quiet you could be on
Esplanade right on the front row next to
the Playa which is the open area with
all the big art installations and you
could be raging I mean you can find a
party at any time you find anything you
want again you can the spectrum is there
choose your adventure my favorite thing
was you know the night times the art
cars the lights the lights are so
beautiful like you can't you can't
explain the lights to people it's just a
sea of color everywhere and so that's
really more intense and energy and then
you know I love like the afternoons just
riding out on the bike to deep Playa and
it was so quiet and you knew there was a
party going on but you also were able to
be peaceful and introspective and then
you'd walk into the temple and the
temple had people crying and you know
for those who don't know the temple is
one of the pieces that they burn it's
the last night and people go and put
their tributes to people that have
passed away in there and so and also put
intentions that they want to free up
when the when it burns down all of it
burns including the pictures and the
tributes and everything I just love that
contrast it's whatever you're up for is
is available the first time I saw the
temple it was in 2019
and I walked in there and I didn't know
what to expect and I see a lot of people
you know crying about their loved ones
and and really like like letting go of
grief
and at first I didn't know what to think
about it because of the contrast you
never know like because you see one side
and it's like whoa whoa like what's
going on there and then you see another
side and it's like very exciting and it
was confusing to me in the beginning
what's really going on here and then I
understood well it's all based on your
perception you know how do you choose to
accept this experience and the way that
I chose to look at the temple and it
turned into the most beautiful thing in
the world is
it was based on my perception of fire
fire being a transformative energy not a
destructive energy forget about
destruction that's a judgment of
transformation it's how do we deal with
our loved ones that passed how do we
connect with them in a different way
it's a processing and then an Alchemy
which is the name of our camp also the
play Alchemist Camp how do we alchemize
something from dirt to gold from sad to
Joy and it's based on a different
perception so when they do that burning
of the temple I see it as more of a
transformation ritual it's it's
transforming alchemizing processing
everything that you're going through in
that case specifically with loved ones
that you know passed on or moved on or
transformed into a different realm or
whatever it may be so
it was interesting but it got a whole
lot more interesting when it started
raining it's very late nights for sure
because so much of the action is at
night and the art cars and everything so
definitely you're out of sync with sleep
schedule I'm kind of a nine to five or
at home when I go to bed at nine pm and
wake up at 5am but it's kind of a five
to nine or when you're there you like go
to bed at 5am wake up at 9am
um but uh you know it would have been a
few days of staying up late and then it
was the full moon while we were there
which is just so magical because
obviously it was so close to full for a
couple of nights before and so it was so
cool to stay up the whole night to see
the sunrise which I got a great picture
of the full moon over the mountains and
then the sun came up and I got a
panoramic picture where they're both in
it the full sun the full moon it was
really beautiful so it was like after
that it was kind of I think that was
then maybe Wednesday morning what
Thursday morning yeah to bed at midnight
that night slept for eight hours did a
recharge night and thought Friday
Saturday and then leave Sunday Friday
Saturday will go hard we'll stay up late
Friday every time it was time to like go
okay let's just go explore get on the
bike sprinkles all right go back in get
on the bike sprinkles ah go back in and
then finally it was like all right the
rain is here and it started pouring and
I didn't walk out of the bus until
Saturday midday like I never left that
left the camper that
um that I had there one of the chefs
that was cooking at the camp he kind of
needed some shelter so he would come in
and the steps in the bus were just like
totally filled with mud oh my God it was
so bad
um and the Cherry sat on right next to
the door was full of it so I was getting
a sense of how bad it was and looking
out the window and just seeing how hard
it was to walk around so you know
Saturday put on like flip-flops and then
tape duct taped bags around
yeah and so no the flip-flops want to
stick the bags don't work like they tear
they pull so then after that you
realized socks what stocks am I going to
sacrifice and that worked first
um but yeah how is it for you did you go
out on Friday night at all and on Friday
night I didn't and it was then when I I
understood I'm like okay because then
everything started getting real you know
it's like okay well we're in the middle
of nowhere
there really isn't service unless you're
you have a place with Wi-Fi which
thankfully I think you had and we had
yeah we and you know that that's how
there was any form of communication
without otherwise there's nothing
otherwise there's nothing and then I
started hearing really weird things
going all around the internet and I'm
like guys I'm here like that's not
that's not true about what like the
outbreaks and the like you're dying like
are you okay are you okay and I remember
being like it's raining yeah like it's
fine like why is everybody so concerned
I kept thinking am I missing something
so they were totally dramatizing it a
hundred percent now when it got real
like when I understood that something
needed to be done was I think it was
Saturday afternoon and I'm like okay
listen they're telling us we might be
here till Wednesday
now some of us have RVs a lot of people
don't and if you're in a tent and your
intent is destroyed I don't have
electricity and flooded and you don't
have electricity water clothes or food
and everybody's gonna have to start
sharing which was done and people were
starting to share and you know with the
whole thing which was great but the
question is if the airspace is locked
which it was and the airport is closed
and exits are closed
how long can we really last like that
and that's when I started going into the
mode and we got to do something here
well and you never know like I mean it's
one thing to be in this sort of space
where there's no money in exchanging and
I'm sure that there are people that
aren't contributing like it's just the
reality of life but there's enough that
it does work there every year then the
thought of like if people start to get
hungry
they will get desperate and if they
don't sleep they'll be out of their
minds yeah and that that's where I
started going I'm like listen we
something needs to be done here yeah I
don't know what but we're gonna have to
figure it out and then I was going in
all directions and I said okay you know
what who can I call that has because
they are we're only letting emergency
vehicles in at some point so I
understood if we wanted to get out there
was a way to get out but I wanted to get
out not just with myself I wanted to see
how can we bring more people with us so
I started doing inquiries with people
with medical helicopters because they
could fit like 16 20. I thought about
helicopters too and you know I've seen
some stuff afterwards about like oh the
rich people probably just get the
helicopter and I was like I did consider
a helicopter
no no but if you do a medical helicopter
you can bring a lot of people with you
you know you can you can actually make
it something where like let's fit as
many people in this as we can of course
yeah you could do a few trips the
problem was yeah it was super illegal to
do that and they wanted to give us like
a twenty thousand dollar fine or a ten
thousand dollars that's not worth it no
so I'm like okay I don't I don't know
what we're gonna do here let's just
figure out how to walk so that's where
the whole
we we walked like you walked out did you
walk in with a girly so for people that
don't know the um Black Rock City the
camp air the whole the the the the
Burning Man itself is a few miles from
the road it's a few miles on a on the on
the same dirt that you end up acidic
sand that ruins oh yeah but you have to
walk to the so the road is a quite a few
miles and then from there it's another
few miles to a little town that has like
a gas station a little restaurant things
like that called Burley so did you walk
to the road or to Gurley no so I went to
I walked to the nearest road on
interstate 34.
they're waiting thankfully it was me and
four other people we started biking
because we had bikes then the bikes died
and then people started getting hurt so
we had somebody on our team earlier I
think he broke his ankle we had another
another girl just like tripping and
falling over like this on mud in general
but then one of the the women with us
she fell and I think she dislocated her
knee and I'm like okay this is getting
bad this is not good and this is the
little group of four of you that we're
walking
well one of them was was part of our
team he stayed back with the RVs okay
and the girl came with us and she yeah
she hurt her knee pretty badly I hope
she's okay now where I'm I'm in touch
with her but that was it was like hard
like mud you know it was it was like
serious gluey weird like quick Sandy
kind of quicksand sticky quicksand mud
it was very rare yeah and then out of
nowhere I saw on my way out I see like
50 police cars going 100 miles an hour
literally it was this
on Saturday on Sunday Sunday Sunday
afternoon right was it sunny around like
two or so three yeah yeah because we
were we were stuck I think I have a
thing right it was intense it was like
we were stuck too and all of a sudden
there's just like we see at least like
20 or so police officers lights on
blazing by us and we were like what the
hell is going on
they were just flying from the highway
yeah everybody boom boom and they were
coming and then I thought I'm like okay
where people start is there a problem
now with people and like you know
getting aggravated frustrated I just
didn't know what to think anymore and
then I think everybody started catching
on and they're like okay you know we got
to figure this out and get out of here
because it can lead to a problem you
know you never know what's gonna happen
so yeah I think at this point I mean
things are settled down you know people
people are good the news does what the
news does you know and well man I mean
when we were stuck like our exit was
like so you know it was Sunday morning
and there was somebody parked sort of
where like at at the side of the the
camper so they couldn't really get out
so we had to pull forward and there was
a plan to leave really early on Sunday
morning when everything was fine and
then with the rain and and everything
and them closing the gates assuming they
closed the gates and no one could get
out we were just waiting for that to
open and pound on the door it was like
10 30 in the morning and it was a late
night so get up and like they're like we
want to leave we're going to make a run
for it some friends have left they got
out this morning they're not stopping
anyone we're gonna go and I'm like let's
go let's go and I had to talk my friend
into it like he was like I don't know
um and I just have a very optimistic
nature to me and a lot of determination
when I set my mind to something and what
I didn't want to happen was that waiting
until it actually opened I was afraid
that was going to take a half a day
because last year when I left it was
during the temple burn on Sunday night
so it was literally still burning
thought maybe everyone will either
choose to stay go before or stay after
and it took 10 hours to get to the road
wow 10 hours so I was like if we wait
until it's open it might take even
longer than that to get to the road and
so then you wait for the opening and
then you have to wait another I was like
let's go let's make a run and so
um so but it was so it was you know just
to tell a story along the way of how
helpful people are once we got to the
spot that there was uh we got really
stuck and look there was a little bit of
adventuring off some bumps because man
you had to keep that bus lit like if you
like slowed down it was so heavy it gets
stuck so um there was some sliding going
on were you the one driving were you
doing your magic no I wasn't driving the
other guy used to race too so he knew
what he was doing
um so I let him drive and um I was
encouraging him to go faster
um but we got to the spot that we were
stuck and
you know people helped us at our camp
they got boards cardboard all kinds of
stuff and some people were kind of
pissed because they're like look there
are bigger problems right now than you
trying to get out when it's not even
open yet and we're like I get it so we
got away but the next time we're stuck
and these guys had this big truck and
they're helping these campers and and
trucking trailers try and get out and
the there's three guys they're literally
covered in mud head to toe speckled all
over his face like covered and they're
putting boards they've got a strap to
like anchor and pull you or push you
know lead you out or pull you back and
um and so they they came over and
they're like we'll totally help you when
we get this guy out we'll help you and
um then at one point uh they said hey
look if you guys you know we we end up
rolling ahead and then stopping because
we got you know we got stuck again and
they said we've got we've got elpas
pastor tacos for you we've got drinks
we've got everything you come over here
you hang out with us tonight like you'll
be taken care of and and these guys were
trying to get out themselves but they
had a truck that could pull so like they
were doing what they could and they had
boards and it was so nice and so anyway
managed to get off the last place which
was it took about 30 minutes of waiting
until it's set it like like sunk in the
water
um drove away and never never let off
from that point on
um and drove like 30 plus miles an hour
on the dirt on the road getting out
which was actually pretty smooth thank
God and um and managed to get out but um
but that's how helpful people were they
were like even if they were pissed and
they were kind of like look we got
bigger problems like we need propane so
that we can cook food for the people
that are still here they were helping
get out and then guys that were trying
to get out they were helping covered in
mud which it's not like showers were the
most common easy thing to find even if
showers were easy to find there you
can't take that mud off of you it's like
it's tough It's it's quite sticky you
have to rub like to you have to rub
everything to get it to get it off off
yeah and so
um but people were super helpful and
they just were like it was beautiful
that was I think one of the really nice
things to see is the rallying of
everyone of going like okay I'm gonna
give you what I can and some of it was
time some of it was resources
um some of it was shelter
um but there was like like for the
record I never saw any real Anarchy the
only thing I saw the only thing I saw
was walking out on Saturday out to uh
the temple because someone was doing
like a Turkish breakfast out there and
like cooking for people so we walked out
with some friends
um there was a girl that was saying like
I had a loud speaker it was right
um was that one of the big round open
areas
um inside of the camps and she was
yelling at people for walking because
you're messing up the road and making it
harder for everyone to get out and then
on the way back we were like yeah
whatever and so as we were walking
though we were literally packing it in
and making pass and like it was getting
dry to walk on where we were walking so
we came back and there was the girl I
think she was just like a Heckler she
was actually kind of a [__] but someone
you can tell when someone's joking and
not and she was probably just a [__]
um but she was on her loudspeaker
yelling at everyone and there was a guy
at this point in time when we came back
that also had a loud speaker and he was
so there's an expression at um Burning
Man called [__] your burn and so he just
kind of kept yelling [__] your
as sitting underneath shelter and last
night she wasn't letting anyone come in
or something like that so that was the
only thing I saw was like a couple
people with loudspeakers go at like
that's like a normal thing like that
that was all I saw like nobody was
fighting nobody was nobody nobody was
even in a bad mood
um no which which was surprising you
know like
from what I saw everybody they're like
you know what listen we're here let's
make the best of it and I think that's a
good lesson for life where it's like
when stuff goes wrong
turn turn you know lemons into lemonade
make it a good thing make it on my way
out you know how I was dressed I was
wearing I have to show you I'm like you
know what let's just make this funny
let's make this a good time like this is
what I look like
yeah I like let's just have a good time
and and and laugh while we're doing what
we're doing no matter and it was hard
like I was like wheezing it was hard it
was very difficult to get out but let's
have Smiles on her faces even if it's
difficult and help whoever needs help
when things go wrong it could be the
rain it could be you're traveling and
your flight gets canceled or your car
breaks down or whatever the thing is and
you literally start to make memories
that is when you actually have the most
Vivid recollect like memories and
experiences and stories like here we are
literally going we need to do a podcast
right away about this because there's so
many stories there's just like it's such
a story if we just went to a regular
Burning Man it wouldn't necessarily you
know register that we needed to talk
about it because it was isn't different
it was kind of just every man every year
but there were so many memories I loved
it I'm personally like I thought it was
so cool to be there this year the only
other year I went was last year last
year was a hundred plus degrees Wicked
win they said last year was one of the
toughest Burns because of the conditions
and then this year
you came to two of the toughest
I thought it was really cool I I thought
it was a cool thing to be a part of the
media dramatized it more than it really
was I couldn't believe that like FEMA
was involved and you know Biden tried to
get some words out about it all the
rumors and all that but you know it goes
to show and what I've learned over the
past two years is you know we're in this
world maybe me a little bit more than
you of of speaking about you know
out there things sometimes and what you
know what I'm talking about and this
this this taught me very clearly
be as calculated as you can possibly be
because there will always be things out
there there will always be stories out
there and you got to be really sure
before you go and speak about something
and say look at what's happening like I
see reels on Instagram right now about
stories of what's really happening at
Burning Man and none of it is true I
mean we were there we know none of what
they're saying is true and there are all
these people that created this alternate
reality that doesn't exist so there's
this fine line right now in this age of
information with so much coming out with
you know conspiracies and these theories
and all that where we need to be really
careful because we're under a magnifying
glass right now and we need to validate
everything that's happening we need to
be very careful with how we choose to
speak about it and we need to verify
before we speak about it otherwise you
know you say look what's happening this
is happening in this part of the world
and it's not well you just lost all your
credibility in anything future even if
it's true because
what you said in the past may have not
been verified you know so it's like it's
a matter of right now that was another
lesson for me be super calculated and
verify everything that you put out
before you put it out because yeah yeah
there's a lot of information that needs
to come out and this world needs to
change very quickly and it is it is
changing and a lot of people are waking
up but if we want to wake up quicker
it's a game of chess that we're playing
right now we got to do it very
calculated yeah and I I mean you know I
think
to
the reality of Burning Man because like
I laugh and sometimes I laugh at myself
I'm like what am I doing I'm like up so
late and like doing all these things you
know all these companies and employees
and like life and it's so different it
is such an alternate reality the whole
thing is not the same like I was
listening to some stuff that Ben Shapiro
and Matt Walsh was saying and you catch
other things and they just sort of you
know have this perspective that it's
basically just this Pagan orgy
everywhere and everyone is doing the
same thing and it's not like I literally
didn't I don't even know where they were
like I never walked into one never had
sex at Burning Man like I I mean they
just seem to think it's like everyone's
just doing that all over the place but
that's not true it's really not true
when I say it's choose your adventure
you can go look at Art you can go you
know play one day went and walked a
labyrinth like you know in a labyrinth
where they yeah I saw that one it's like
one way in one way out it was like walk
to Labyrinth there was like there was
also you know kite surfing on surfboards
where like the wind would catch you I
mean there's just so many things to do
that you don't and not everything is
hedonistic and extreme I mean everything
is available there sometimes I laugh and
I think I was saying like there's cops
everywhere that's also another thing
that people don't know there are police
everywhere
everywhere like you can get in trouble
if you get caught doing something or
whatever like and I you know laugh like
obviously there's a lot going on there
and you know but you know these cops are
walking around make sure everything's
okay and keeping people as honest as
possible it's not that everyone that
goes is having sex in a group under in a
tent and you know
staying up all day every day just doing
drugs it's I mean everything's available
but that is like a small fraction of
people like it's not that yeah it's not
it's not everything that's going on
there and it's a shame you know when
there's a small group of people that
does something that's extreme suddenly
it creates this narrative for anybody
that's associated with anything you know
what I mean because it really is I mean
it's beautiful there's the art there it
shows the genius of humankind of what
we're capable of in our in our lens of
creativity you know so I'm totally with
you on that and I I've been hearing you
know like oh it's like ritualistic and
like Satan and this and I'm like you
know what let's talk about that for a
second why why why and they're like well
there's a pyramid and there's an
All-Seeing Eye and uh 666 and 13 and I'm
like okay well one and I actually just
posted about this the other day and I
basically said you know what I'm going
to read it to you I I need to read it to
you right now because it needs to be
said and needs to be heard basically the
post says this I wrote let's talk about
something important every day more and
more people believe that everything is
somehow a satanic symbolism
it's become so prevalent that I feel
compelled to clarify a few things for
centuries individuals and those in
positions of power have controlled the
minds of many and this influence
persists today have you ever considered
whether these people these very people
who propagate the notion that specific
numbers and geometric shapes are
malevolent might be doing so to instill
fear and deter us for embracing the
truly liberating aspects of our divine
reality
due to a lack of awareness we've allowed
a handful of people to hijack our
Consciousness and suddenly everything
once sacred is now connected to Satan I
see people inadvertently giving their
power away to false authoritative
figures failing to recognize that we
contribute to our mental imprisonment
through engagement in confusion and
division thus perpetuating our
self-imposed limitations
we've reached the point that I have no
choice but to say something and stand up
for Humanity's bright future and
promising future our Unity begins with
self-awareness it's time to wake up and
live as free Sovereign human beings it's
time to end all division then I wrote
Let's get a few things clear a pyramid
is not evil it represents humankind's
connection between the physical and
spiritual worlds 33 is not an evil
number it's a master number with a lot
of power when used correctly 13 is not
an unlucky number it represents the
Resonance of Love 18 which by the way is
666 when you add it up is not a satanic
number it represents life and the
All-Seeing Eye is not an evil symbol it
represents protection and good luck
and then it goes on by saying
unfortunately some individuals have used
these Powers the power of these shapes
and numbers negatively such as certain
groups and individuals out there that
doesn't mean these numbers and shapes
are inherently bad intention is
everything and certain individuals and
groups have decided with their own free
will to use these things to do harm
instead of good so we Face a fundamental
question well we use our free will
positively and for the betterment of
humanity or will we allow the will of
others to shape our perception of the
world
my mission is to unite humanity and I
will continue to do that no matter what
type of adversity comes my way my vision
for our world is clear may we choose to
tap into Universal awareness once and
for all we have everything we need
within us to do this the choice is ours
to make what do you choose
well the two words that come up that I
think would be interesting for us to
kind of Riff and talk about based on our
experiences burning man but then life
itself is
judgment and fear because one of the
things that burning man that's very
prevalent is there's really no judgment
yeah I mean I'm sure it exists right
because we're still human beings but
like it is so low that I don't ever
really notice it and there's again
everything I mean there are people
walking around completely naked like
it's there right I've seen that
um I saw a naked parade one day last
year it was like day two and it was
really really windy and I had goggles on
I was glad I was a naked parade going on
um and I'm not judging it's just
different right and so you have to have
such low to no judgment there because
there's so much going on and so I think
that that's something that is so
beautiful when you're in that space and
then there's and then then the word fear
really makes me think about the people
that speak about it as if they
understand what it's all about and I
think that usually When We Fear
something we tend to push it away
because we don't know how else to deal
with it it's not something that we When
We Fear something we kind of we we put
it down because we don't understand it
and so that's why I think this is great
for us to talk about the understanding
of it from someone who goes and
participates a burning man loves it
for their reasons which are not you know
I mean staying up late okay
um you know there's some things that go
on that aren't my normal routine but
there's really no judgment there is that
how you feel when you go 100 100 and
it's it's a release in a way too you
know you're you're finally able to go
into a world where it doesn't matter
it's okay be who you are be who you want
to be smile love give receive do what
you want to do do with respect do with
compassion have a good time come back
and do your best to bring that energy
with you to the outside world as well
you know it's like the world isn't that
unfortunately hopefully one day we'll be
able to get to a world where everybody
really is here to help each other you
know and everybody really is here to
come together and support each other and
I believe we'll get there
and uh it's it's almost like for me it
was it was a little piece of that along
the way now there were also other things
as you mentioned that are the opposite
side of the spectrum with those other
choices it was hard for me to be around
those things you know so it's not a
judgment it's more of a resonance a
feeling so I stay away from those things
and then I gravitate towards the
let me stick to what I love you know I
mean things available everything's
available so you get to choose it's it's
free will yeah what do you think about
the fear like what do you you know I
think that you know that's really a
prevalent thing for a lot of people I
think even I you know I even heard from
the people that you know helped uh that
ended up getting the camper from they're
like I don't know Burning Man seems a
little intense I'm a little scared it's
like there's a general amount of fear
around it and and why do you think that
is I think fear usually stems from
uncertainty and the unknown world
it could be not just fear of for example
let's say somebody fears going it could
be fear of who am I what am I going to
find out about myself I found a lot
about myself this past week
and some of it is great and some of it
is a shadow and those things we have to
look at and be like oh like how does
this make me feel you know so it's and
that's that's just the transparent truth
I had moments where I'm like oh I this
this this needs to change and it's I I
don't know about that that's not where I
want to go again not judgment
self-awareness to be able to get to the
point that you strive to get to whatever
that point may be so I think it's fear
of uncertainty which I don't think is a
problem
it only becomes a problem if that fear
stops you because sometimes I'm scared
shitless before I do something that's
the truth but I need to do it anyways
because I know that there's something on
the other side I know it's going to be
uncomfortable I know there are going to
be pieces of that where I'm like oh my
God what does this mean about me what do
I feel about myself what am I uncovering
what am I going to learn next that's
what's going to happen that's that's
what change is and change implies
uncertainty you have no clue what's
about to happen next that scares people
you know it scares people because what
if they don't like what comes next you
know what if they don't like a piece of
what they see I think the world right
now is comfortable with being
uncomfortable because at least they know
what uncomfortable feels like well just
it's familiar whatever they have that's
not comfortable is familiar so they know
they won't die from it which is just the
ego's job of going okay look we're
mitigating against the worst possible
scenario here and so you're used to
doing this yeah it's not good for you
but we know how to handle that and
you're going to make it where the this
might be worse so let's just push that
away let's do the familiar it's like
we're a computer because maybe we are
and wants to run the program that it's
been running over and over again and
it's really hard to you know
biologically upload the new program and
and and cancel and delete the other one
that's a process and so most people just
stay in the program that's that's
definitely the way that I've been seeing
the world more and more moving forward
I'm writing a book right now called
accessing awareness and it's all about
the program of the mind you know how it
works what the reflection of that is how
do you tap into the program to become
the equivalent of a programmer because
that's what we are only instead of you
know Cobra C plus C plus plus HTML and
JavaScript we're using emotions beliefs
words music color food it's all a game
it's all a code and it's sick it's so
cool so I'm curious I was having a
conversation with somebody not long ago
about the concept of free will and if we
actually even have it
because when you think about why we do
what we do in a day it comes from our
programming and our programming comes
from usually our environment our parents
very very much so especially our
emotional reactions are coming from
those sort of roots from parenting it
comes from the parents parents so it
comes from ancestral lineage so I'm
curious your thoughts about free will
so there's a chapter called the
different dimensions of will in this
book okay and I'm going to give you a
different perspective I don't know where
it came from it's probably a combination
of many things that you know I just
marinated with and and it came from
somewhere but it's it changed my life
when I when I saw this New Perspective
so let's start with this
ego and so
Spirit whatever you want to call it
right
we're taught that the ego is like this
bad thing you know you got to stay away
from it you got to kill the ego no no
you you wouldn't have it if it was bad
we just need to learn how to use it the
right way free will
Divine will
Free Will is the will of the body
Divine will is the will of the Soul
Free Will is your body self Divine will
is your higher self I'm giving you all
this different terminology for anybody
listening to understand in whatever way
they connect to the most when we come
into this body
so let's first start with this the the
goal is to align Free Will with Divine
One if we can align Free Will with
Divine will you become Unstoppable the
question is how do we do that so imagine
this
you're in a car you know those cars with
two steering wheels when you're learning
how to drive oh yeah he didn't need it
he wanted the brake a lot but he didn't
need the other wheel
so imagine sitting in one of those cars
okay you're sitting in one of those cars
only you're the teacher and the student
you're the driving teacher and the
person learning how to drive you're on
this road only when you come into the
body you now have this like plastic
thing that's blocking your view from
each other so your free will in your
driver's seat can't see the Divine will
version of you standing next to you or
sitting in the car next to you but both
are steering the wheel
the path in front of you is your destiny
it's your purpose that's something that
you can say is like a predetermined
potential
but if there was a predetermined
potential that took away your free will
then what's the point of being a human
being
so we get this piece where we're allowed
to Veer however we want on the road
however
on each side of the road there's trees
there's metal spikes there's danger
and when we Veer you don't want to hit
because you're going to get hurt the
purpose of divine will is to jerk you
right back onto the road so with your
free will you can choose to go off path
but if you choose to go off path and the
further you go off path the closer you
get to Danger the harder The Jerk will
will be back onto the road
and the hardware the harder your head
hits the window
and that can be in real life cancer
diabetes disease hardship obstacles
there's nothing in this world that comes
here to hurt you there's nothing in this
world that happens to you it's all
happening for you so how can a hardship
or an obstacle in your life
be a positive thing and I would argue
that it's divine will doing its best
without saying what to do telling free
will get back on the road and if we
don't listen those messages get louder
because we're veering further and
further and further that's how it
usually happens in life we get hurt a
little bit if we don't hear the message
it gets louder and louder and louder and
louder until we either listen or we
transition we come back and we try again
I think the goal is to align Free Will
and divine will the desire of the ego
with the desire of the soul and if your
desire of the ego is dictated by your
destiny potential and journey in your
life of what you came here you now have
an engine working in the Physical Realm
and the spiritual realm you become a
rocket shift that can't be stopped it's
all about congruence and Alignment so I
think we have free will but we have
Divine will as our backup that shows us
the way along the way I love that so
then what's the benefit of doing things
like going to Burning Man and sort of
like Galaxy like touching the edges you
know you kind of like start to touch the
edges of living expression reality you
know like you you kind of push it right
and and it's not my normal life but what
what is the benefit of that
the same benefit of when I went to Dubai
you get to see the beauty of creation
Now I wasn't excited to go to Dubai
because I'm like this is all artificial
I want to go to Nature show me a big
tree I was just inside or like an
ancient city right or something 100 I
wanted to see something real but then I
understood when I got there I'm like let
me make the best of it so I looked
around me and I'm like this may not be
natural
but this is genius this is a creation of
somebody or a few people that came
together to create such designs that
show you the beauty of the creative lens
that we have as human beings and in that
way it's beautiful may not be a tree or
a mountain but it's still made up of
elements that they just happen to
manipulate from nature into what we call
a building so it wouldn't be my first
choice but there's a beauty to it it
shows you a different side of humanity
it shows you a different lens of who we
are of the capabilities that we have
technically the pyramids aren't natural
either they took Stone and put it into
place how they did it is a whole
different story
but that is the genius of humankind and
what we're able to do and that's how I
saw burning man I I think it just shows
you other potentials you know when
you're when you're looking at different
shapes Robert Grant taught me this when
you're looking at different geometry you
know and you're you're drawing these
different shapes it's like a QR code to
different Consciousness and as you draw
them and look at them you're tapping
into that QR code you're tapping into
that new awareness of the energy of that
shape that's a whole world to begin with
it's it's pretty awesome what do you
think it is with burning man I think
it's to to learn more about yourself you
know even just through fashion like
right like especially girls but you know
you know guys too but just like what do
you actually want to wear somebody was
asking before we went like it was like
what should I wear I'm like it's not
burning man style that you should be
trying to achieve you should be trying
to say what do I like to wear and how
far do I want to take that that's the
style I that's cool I like that it's
like your own personal adventure with
creativity you know like I found myself
like theming it up every day I was like
oh it is like red and then another day's
like well look and then other days like
uh you know like they just had kind of
like almost themes and I was like oh how
playful could I get with this you know
and um and definitely all about free the
nipple I think that in my regular life
anyway but you know didn't feel near bad
at all there
um I find them be stupid I hate bras and
look I get some girls have big boobs big
nipples whatever the situation is
I don't please don't be mad at me
um so I think it's for me it feels like
um feels like a way you can kind of
start to see your own edges yeah right
and then the question in every situation
is like what's my part in this and why
am I reacting the way I'm reacting and
so it's almost like the more reaction
you have the more you have to learn
learn
like why do I care if someone's naked
yeah like or why do I care if they're
doing an orgy or why do I care if
they're climbing on that saying that
looks like they might fall off or you
know why do I care about staying up late
for a few days like you know look so
you're you know for me I'm able to look
at like my rigidity like my routine my
uh you know how much I like to take care
of myself and how I don't like to go
outside of those sort of bounds very
often 100 like how can I relax like one
of the things is me I was riding my bike
so fast everywhere and it was like slow
the [__] down and I'm like all right you
can call you set the pace from here on
out and I was like wow that was really
nice and like I for myself I'm just
going from point A to B point B I do
everything so fast so it was a way for
me to go what do I what what is my part
in this or like what does this say about
me what do I have to learn oh my God you
know enjoy the journey look at the art
along the way stop trying to get from
deep plyo 11 all the way back to camp at
four like just chill for me I think
that's what it's about is all of it the
healthiest no like look they're staying
up late there's drinking there's drugs
like there's everything that you could
want to do there when you get into these
uncomfortable places or these unfamiliar
places you're like what is this saying
about me like why am I afraid to dance
like why why don't I what makes me not
feel like I should be dancing right now
or like I want to like am I embarrassed
or you know and you just you see people
in Freedom there and it's really cool
and so I find that I like get out I push
my edges out a little there well yeah
I'm curious to see how everything
unfolds moving forward
we'll see what happens in future years
and uh I think we just have a whole
world also to explore and and taking
that energy with you everywhere that you
go in a positive way and see how we can
radiate that positivity everywhere that
we go you do so many like very cool
crazy interviews where people are
sharing such extreme information you
know where do you see things going like
I mean obviously we have events like
burning man and then you have you know
news being spread in extreme ways but
you also talk to them about so many
other things so like from a macro
perspective of all the conversations
you've been having in the sort of
exposing more truths about what's going
on from people on the inside like where
are we going
well macro macro always to a good place
micro the question is what's going to
happen along the way you know like how
much how much damage needs to occur
until Humanity as a whole not just a few
of us but the collective decides to say
enough is enough and we want to make a
change a lot of people when they hear
you know about the work that I do the
organization that I work with TLS there
some people everybody has their own
opinion on it but my biggest concern
always was I never wanted people to
Outsource their power to be like oh
there are heroes working behind the
scenes because that's not how this works
that's that's out of a movie
the hero is you
their job is to activate us their job is
to help us see who we are so do they do
things behind the scenes do they do
things undercover yeah and they do a
great job at it to the best of their
ability but they're not the ones here to
save anybody nobody can save anybody
other than ourselves and that's the
message that people need to understand
and hear over here so
it's a great
interesting you know
series of interviews that you're talking
about with a lot of information that are
going to continue but the key to getting
out of this and the fastest way to get
out of this is by diving as deep into it
as we possibly can you have to dive into
the darkest places in the world if you
want to light this world up because if
you don't light up those dark places
what are we going to do if we focus on
only you know the sunshine rainbows
everything's great well I mean news
flash it's not there are problems around
the world you know so we need to look at
those things and we need to alchemize
them not to look at them and you know
worry and be in fear and concerned and
oh my God this is horrible but to
acknowledge the problem so we know that
there is one so then we know how to fix
it and we take those steps and
in short we're going to a good place I
mean a a destiny of what I would call
light peace and love for real light
peace and love for all I think it's
inevitable the question really is just
how long is it going to take what's
going to happen along the way and I just
do my part as a little piece of the
puzzle to do my best to you know raise
awareness and so do you you do a great
job with the people you interview you
know you talking about the collective
that's the word that struck me is so
important it's that it's the
participation and so like going back to
our sort of point of our conversation
being Burning Man everyone has chosen to
participate with these sort of 10 rules
with I mean like I don't know about you
but it's crazy how little garbage there
is there because there's a note no no no
no left you can't leave a trade no leave
no Trace like you know you you have your
own cup so if you people are serving
drinks you have to have your own cup
they don't give you a cup so like
there's really no garbage like they're
not producing any and people are super
responsible
um but but people participate there in
in this in in the with these rules and
and and it's interesting because the
rules kind of actually create the
freedom so I'm not opposed to having
some rules right people participate in a
way that keeps it going and so it's the
collective that has the power like if
half the people there decided that they
weren't going to participate in that
same way well now like you know
obviously maybe federal wouldn't let us
do it like to have a problem 100 things
go away so you know if you don't like
the news stop watching it if you don't
want like what the newspaper has to say
stop buying it if you don't want your
stuff made in another country stop
buying that too buy from some like if if
if the collective participates on a
large scale in the way that is the right
way to move forward with things then
that is exactly what will happen like no
one person
might be wrong to say this but no one
person is going to change the world it
really like someone could have an idea
but it can only be something that
inspires the masses to do it too it
needs to be an activation for all so one
person may be able to activate something
right there are some people that are
like in this you know mentality of oh
they're here to save us they can't even
if they wanted to they can't nobody can
do anything for you it's like your body
like I can't heal your body a doctor
doesn't heal you a Healer doesn't heal
you they're just facilitators for your
body to do what it does best which is
heal itself and if your body chooses not
to do that there's going to be an issue
so we need it we need to like shift the
way that we see things it's not the
person giving you something it's the
person helping activate something within
you that you already have sure how much
you believe it's going to work and how
much you believe in yourself it was such
a fun event it was so cool I hope we I
hope you go back I hope we see each
other there we're gonna need some time
I'm gonna need some time yeah yeah the
first time I went I thought the first
couple days were trying and it was so
hot and I didn't I didn't know I need
gas for a generator and it was a lot of
work like you know it was a lot of work
and I was like screw this man I don't
need to come back every year and then by
the end of it kind of got in the flow
and as soon as I left I was like that
was so cool I'll be back so yeah it's uh
it's an adventure
um but it's a learning adventure and
just such an alternate reality
um that just stretches your mind and
your in in your emotions and your
perspective on just like what's possible
and what's available I enjoyed this
conversation very much yeah me too
thanks Jason
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button